13 months have passed since the final
episode of the last Kingdom and Netflix
has graced us with a feature-length
movie to tie up the story of utread of
bebenberg and thank the gods it's
actually pretty good in this video we'll
be taking a look at seven Kings must die
it's real history and the fate of many
of its characters and if you need a
refresher as to what happened in season
5 I've left a link to my recap video in
the description below if Destiny has led
you this far hit that like And subscribe
button because I cover tons of
historical shows the events of seven
Kings Must Die begin around the death of
King Edward in 924 A.D this is 13 years
before the battle of bernen bear which
solidified King ethelstan and unified
England as one this might come as a
surprise considering the pacing of the
movie feels as though all these events
happen over the course of a few weeks
but hey this is what happens when you
don't have an entire season with the
King's death comes a time of political
instability and with it those who seek
to exploit this tumultuous time for
their own game one such person is Olaf
gutferson who in the show is referred to
as Old English name anlaf king of
Ireland or Ireland he seeks to unite the
tribal Kings of England against evil
Stan who he believes is a threat to
their sovereignty but as the show
suggests his real goal is to eventually
take over the land for himself part of
Olaf's plan is cementing a spy deep
within Ethel Stan's Inner Circle in
Comes ingelmunder Who indeed was a Norse
Viking driven out from Ireland who
settled in the wheel Peninsula however
the whole Act of him being a devout
Christian who uses his sexuality to
manipulate the king is unfounded in fact
there is no definitive evidence to
suggest that King ethelstan was gay only
that there is a lack of documented
marriages or offspring so the writers
here are definitely taking some artistic
Liberties by grounding ethelston's
desire to unite England and Christendom
in his fear that he'll go to hell for
being gay as inglemunder tells him every
sin can be weighed against an Act of
Faith if ethelsten unites England this
Act of Faith according to inglemunder
will negate his act of sin but standing
in ethelstan's way is utrid of bebenberg
who at the end of season 5 ruled the
kingdom of northumbria acting as a sort
of buffer between King Edward in the
South and King Constantine of Scotland
in the north Utrecht was promised that
he would give up the land as soon as
ethelstand proved himself to be the
rightful King and so far Ethel Stan has
not proven that in fact he kills his own
half-brother elf weird for fear that he
would make claim to the throne in
reality elf weird's cause of death is
unknown he died only 16 days after King
Edward's Death which is rather
suspicious with some historians even
suggesting that he was poisoned so that
big scene where ethelsten stabs and
kills his own brother probably didn't
happen but what that scene did do was
prove to utra that ethelstan is not the
rightful king or at least not yet so
utrid doesn't bend the knee or at least
not until Ethel Stan his crown sound and
to make matters worse utra doesn't even
show up to his coronation but as utrad
later tells us this was all a test I did
not provoke him
simply giving him time to prove he's not
a tyrant lutry doesn't feel comfortable
handing over his kingdom to a man who
may wind up a tyrant and a tyrant he
becomes manipulated by Englander he
tears down Pagan relics banishes utrid
and forcibly takes his land thankfully
utread is picked up by Olaf's men or
should I say women and brought to the
Shetland Islands were a gathering of
Kings occurs this is where the prophecy
of the seven Kings comes into play early
on ingrith wife of finnin exclaims that
she's been experiencing prophetic dreams
in them she claims that if a unified
England is ever to happen that quote
seven Kings must die and the woman you
love so let's take a look at who those
seven kings are and this mystery woman
on one side we have king ethelstan of
Wessex Mercia in East Anglia who will
later piss off the six other kings of
Scotland strathclyde Wales orkney
Shetland and man now there are other
kings in this story however the prophecy
does not State specifically which kinds
must die so when utrid is brought before
Olaf and the other Kings as king of
northumbria in Exile he realizes that
this prophecy is looking more and more
like a reality but there's also another
part to the prophecy a woman you love
who also dies it's actually not a
reference to who utrid loves but rather
his friend finnin and this woman is the
prophecy maker herself his wife ingrath
she'll later die after being entombed
which may have been an apt punishment
considering Christ's body was held in a
tomb prior to his resurrection but
unbeknownst to us utrid finds that
inglemunder is a secret spy for Olaf and
thus he travels back to ethelstan under
the guise of bending the knee only to
tell him that his lover has been
stabbing him in the back and not the fun
kind of stabbing ethelston at first
doesn't believe him but as Olaf unloads
men at inglemunders Garrison at will it
becomes ever the more apparent that
ethelston has been deceived this leaves
the king in a dire situation it's now
him in utrid versus the might of six
other kings and they are heavily
outnumbered this culminates in the
film's climate and battle the battle of
bernenburg which occurred in August of
937. in reality ethelston was caught off
guard not expecting Olaf and the Kings
to start a campaign so late in the
summer and when Olaf made landfall and
started terrorizing the citizens of
ethelstan's Kingdom ethelstan gathered
what available Army he could in order to
contain any further damage at the same
time he tried to stall the Kings with
fake negotiations to give him more time
to gather men he even pitched empty
tents to make it seem to his enemy that
he had more men than he actually did his
efforts weren't in vain and he was able
to stall for three days mustering about
ten thousand men although official
numbers aren't known it is said Olaf and
the other King's Army to be of the same
size so the writers here really
downplayed the strength of Ethel's Den's
Army to give them this Underdog feel now
if you want a full breakdown of the
actual battle itself I suggest you take
a look at baz battle's video on this
subject which I'll leave a link to in
the description below while the movie
depicts this secret flank attack by
utrid's Calvary in reality it was an
extremely long and bloody battle that
lasted several hours with both sides
making almost no progress that is until
ethelstan's forces and managed to pierce
its way through an opening and break
Olaf's Army in two thousands died in the
Battle along with Constantine's son two
of ethelson's cousins and four other
future kings making five Kings dead in
total technically it's princes but the
show plays fast and loose with a
prophecy since these princes will
eventually become Kings so ethelstan is
Victorious and gets his sweet revenge on
inglemunder but all is not well during
the battle utrid was severely wounded we
see him clutching his sword Serpent's
breath which he had forged all the way
back in season 1 episode 2 the Amber orb
here is of significant personal value to
utrid as it was gifted to him by his
father it's only fitting then that utra
dies defending his people just like his
father did well that's the question
isn't it did utra die as ethelsnan and
mind osber pearlig and idgafu pray for
his health he emerges from his chain
Chambers through defying the king utrid
actually saved him and thus the hope for
England utrad now sees that ethelstan
has proved himself to be the rightful
King and will swear northumbria to him
thus England was formed but this still
leaves the question of the prophecy
seven kings were to die but only five
died in the Battle who are the other two
utrid surmises that one of them must be
King Edward for a unified England could
only come after his death then who is
the last king You could argue that it's
ethelstan as utrad makes him vow never
to marry or have heirs thus he has no
child to pass his kinship to but I think
this oath is more so to line up with
history as indeed Ethel Stan never
married or had children and his younger
brother Edmund would become the next
king of England therefore I believe
utrid is the final King who dies it
lines up better with a prophecy since
his death coincides with the end of his
rule of northumbria remember that the
other kings at the Isle of Man did refer
to him as the king of northumbria plus
utrud even says that he doesn't care
care about being remembered by history
rather that he only be honored in a
feast hall for standing by his oath and
this is what happens we hear a crowd
cheering as utread is bathed in light at
a great feast and at this Feast are
memorable characters from utrad's Life
who have also died such as Brita Earl
Ragnar clappa and heisten the voiceover
claims that we don't know if utread
survived his wound or not leaving it up
to us to make our own interpretation the
final shot is uttered standing between
life on the left and Valhalla on the
right we never see which one he chooses
if it's even a choice at all he's framed
in this almost holy-like pose
accompanied with a crown-like fixture
adorned with candles above him and the
last image he looks at is of his son and
notice the distorted lens as if he's
losing his grip on this world but I feel
like his death is a fitting end to the
show and sorry to be that guy but utra
to bevenberg is a fictional character
and is only somewhat inspired by an utra
that would only come along about 100
years later after the events of the last
Kingdom but what is real is bebenberg
Castle which we see at the end
completely redone in stone just like
finnin told him they were going to do
you can actually visit this Castle in
Northumberland for 15 and a half pounds
admission but what did you think of
seven Kings must die I want to hear your
thoughts in the comments below thanks
for watching please make sure to like
And subscribe and for more bad takes you
can follow me on Twitter and Instagram
at thinkstory YT until next time
remember only the king
of the king